Alan Chan is a PhD student at Mila the
Montreal Institute for learning
algorithms supervised by Nicholas de
Rooks
before joining Miele Allen was a
master's student at the Alberta machine
intelligence Institute and the
University of Alberta where he worked
with Martha White Allen's expertise and
research interests Encompass value
alignment and AI governance he's
currently exploring the measurement of
harms from language models and the
incentives that agents have to impact
the world his projects have examined the
regulation of explainability in
algorithmic systems scoring rules for
performative binary prediction the
effects of global exclusion in AI
development and the role of a graduate
student in approaching the ethical
impacts in AI Research In addition Allen
has conducted Research into inverse
policy evaluation for value-based
sequential decision making and the
concept of normal accidents and AI
systems Allen's research is motivated by
the need to align AI systems with human
values and his passion for scientific
and governance work in this field Alan's
energy and enthusiasm for this field is
infectious I caught up with Alan at
Europe's the other week he was Manning
the desk uh talking all about AI
alignment that the desk was open all day
for folks to come up and have a
conversation and this was my short
conversation that I had with Alan enjoy
I'll be honest with you I am intuitively
skeptical of alignment can you keep that
camera and path open I'm so sorry
um yeah so what do I need to and
obviously I know the basics About You
Know instrumental convergence and I've
read Bostrom and I've recently read a
book I think called The Hitchhiker's
Guide to rationalism something I've I've
got I've got some of the basics yeah so
um you know sketch it out I'm interested
in like your your areas of skepticism
though okay um
because I think the problem is it's got
such a horrible lens on it you need to
be quite far back because I want to get
I want to get all of this in right right
I know you just need to like
um yeah just get your elbows out
really hard but it was such an expensive
lens you know like when you choose a
lens you have to get the right one and
that was the one you know I'm poor
I don't get paid for my YouTube
anyway um sponsors
well yeah no one or two yeah we've got
one or two sponsors every now and then
but you know yeah you know we're we're
struggling money if he's holding the
name yeah okay okay
yeah yeah so just I guess um calibrate
myself what are your uh you know
skepticisms okay so um I mean I'm a fan
of Francois and Francois Chile is well
known uh do you remember he wrote an
article called something like the
implaus ability of the intelligence
explosion so most of my skepticism is
along the lines of I think that there
are all sorts of bottlenecks in large
systems I mean if you look at Google he
cites as an example of a super
intelligence and it's it's hit a scaling
factor and the reason for that is
because externalized and distributed it
takes a long time to get the pull
request done it takes a long time to get
code checked into they're a bottlenecks
everywhere even with um you know the
kind of Hardware that we use for
computing there are bottlenecks in
creating the silicon and distribution
and so on so my intuition is that
there's a there's a scaling bottle like
that yeah it seems kind of reasonable I
guess my take is that certainly there do
seem to be bottlenecks with systems that
we're building right now or have built
like Google for instance but it seems a
bit more plausible to me that AIS might
be able to escape these bottlenecks so
issues with communication for instance
at Google right um it seems like an AI
would have a much easier time of
communicating with different copies of
itself around the world let's say I'm
achieving a certain goal um I guess we
can get into like more nitty-gritty like
bottlenecks but um yeah did you have
like sort of more core uh like sources
of skepticism
well another thing is so again reading
that that um that book and again I'm
sure it's an extremely low resolution
View and into what you folks think but
um a lot of it comes back to the
definition of intelligence that some of
you folks choose to use and it's it's
based on a single principle it's a
unifying principle which is this idea of
a rationalist agent making a trajectory
of of you know kind of Bayesian optimal
decisions and I think it's got It's very
elegant I think it's beautiful and you
know like AIX I as a mathematical theory
is is wonderful but I think it's
intractable and I subscribe to different
views of intelligence so you know you
using this AIX side conception You could
argue that something like Alpha zero is
super intelligent because it performs so
well at a particular thing and I think
task specific skill is not the same
thing as intelligence I think
intelligence is the information
conversion ratio the ability to be
flexible and to very quickly given a
small amount of information experience
and priors do something completely
different to what I was trained on so
and there are other views of
intelligence as well like based on
behavior and function and capability and
so on but um I think most of it traces
back I mean certainly instrumental
convergence straight traces it back to
this idea of you know having this
absolute will to do one thing at you
know potentially let's kill all the
humans on the planet in pursuit of doing
this one particular thing
yeah so I guess there are two things
here the first thing you mentioned was
this idea that you know when we think
about on the classical super
intelligence argument it sort of
considers agents to be consequentialists
um pursuing some ACT the second sort of
thing you mentioned
um it was about
um like Intelligence being more than
just like narrow task performance yeah
so I guess on the first thing I think
to what you said
um so I guess like I do agree that the
story for machine learning systems that
we're building nowadays is a little bit
more complicated we're not building like
pure utility maximizers
um but I guess I have a lot of
uncertainty about like to what extent
like how far do we need to go to
building pure utility maximizers to get
to some level of danger
um we are building some time so I guess
let's improvised Learning Systems um
like you know gbd3 right it's not
totally clear but this is a you know
agent that is pursuing some reward when
you train it with reinforcement learning
of human feedback though you know it
seems a little bit closer to this
because you're literally training it to
maximize some reward in some unspecified
way would reinforcement learning systems
like full-on reinforcement learning
systems I think you get much closer to
the classical threatening model in
Boston I think that's sort of um you
know the type of worry coming from
people who worry about uh you know out
of control artificial intelligence
um so so yeah I think it is an open
question you know to what extent do we
get the types of generalization like
failures that actually occur like you
know I think the ml Community has done a
lot of work in the past few years and
trying to formalize power seeking and
trying to find examples in which you
know the goals we specify at training
time don't generalize um you know to
test time and like I think you know this
works uh has been pretty good um and
like showing that this thing can
actually occur in like simple
environments and like there might be
more theoretical reasons for us to
believe that things we're going to clear
more complex environments but of course
we need evaluation to figure out you
know exactly how exactly is this going
to occur and like you know um it is
going to be as easy it affects when we
Scale Models up as you know with models
right now
yeah you said some really interesting
things I mean um I'll touch first on the
reinforcement learning for human
feedback
um and I I worry that something like
that is going to make us Fooled by
Randomness because we anthropomorphize
models like gbt3 and I noticed when I
use dbt3 that I am Fooled by Randomness
it's absolutely incredible right it's
really really incredible and I only
noticed failures when I'm using it
non-interactively as part of a software
stack or in a workflow engine or
something like that and it's because we
we cherry pick quite a lot but I I agree
that it has meaningfully you know it
it's made it almost deterministic when
you greedily sample from gbt3 that it
then it's doing something that I want it
to do which is very interesting but I
could cynically go back to sales
argument you know which is that
basically in lieu of biology computers
don't have any intentionality right and
it's impossible to replicate an
intelligence in silico that's an extreme
argument that you could make that
argument um as well I also wanted to
touch on your um there's a certain
language that I'd that I hear from from
your your part of the world and a lot of
it is words like utility and it sort of
words around
um the I think like related to um uh you
know economic theory and utilitarianism
and consequentialism and um I'm also
quite interested to hear your take on
what a rational agent would do in
respect of moral reasoning um you know
over long trajectories so there's
there's a few things there that I'd like
to understand yeah so in terms of the
terminology
um it's pretty interesting I guess um
the standard framework of machine
learning now is to frame things maybe
not in terms of utility they call it
loss function but it's kind of the same
thing and I think really this comes from
the field of optimization which like
really got Headway you know in the 20th
century when we're thinking about okay
you know how exactly do we design
economies and like how exactly do we
like Design Systems to achieve some goal
effectively right and there I think it's
very natural to see oh like let's think
consequentially how to design these
systems
um and maybe this is a problem right
because I think a lot of the risk from
AI comes from having like consequential
systems that pursue some goal without
caring about anything else or any other
side constraints like okay like maybe
like maybe these humans actually have
values that are like worth preserving
right like yeah
um what was the second thing you
mentioned could I touch that I mean
first of all I I think consequentialism
is a risk for human reasoning as well as
artificial intelligence reasoning now
I'm not going to say state that I have
an opinion on this but I know one of the
criticisms of some of the um the
long-termest community is this notion or
I mean certainly um folks like Bostrom I
think believe
um that the universe is made of
information which leads very quickly to
this simulation hypothesis which leads
very quickly to considering the utility
of future simulated humans on other
planets and so on and I can't remember
the exact number but I I think he did
some kind of calculations which led to a
very very big number let's say times 10
to the power of 59 or something and
because that number is so much bigger
than the number of humans on the planet
now it logically leads to the reasoning
that we should care more about those
lives than these lives so but anyway and
what about the utility function action
as well one of the issues I have with
let's say reward is enough and
reinforcement learning and this
rationalist conception of intelligence
is that the reward function would
necessarily need to be so complicated
and we live in a complex system so you
know the problem is with any phenomenon
of a macroscopic complex system every
time you create an abstraction or some
kind of way of understanding that system
you exclude almost all of the truth of
that system which means any utility
function would really struggle to
capture the Dynamics of that system I
agree and this is why I'm quite
pessimistic actually about alignment I
think if we're building consequentialist
type agents it seems pretty hard that
we're going to be able to get them not
to pursue some kind of power seeking so
this is why I think you know the most
feasible path to getting to a sort of
safe all this coordination where we come
together and we agree okay now we have
like some sort of evidence from
researchers that our AI systems do XYZ
and like YZ are particularly dangerous
and like conditions ABC lead to why is
that so with his evidence we agree okay
let's not build systems in this way
right now sort of like the wild west we
don't really know what's going on a lot
of people have this like intuition
including me that like okay like we're
building kind of wild systems let's
maybe like slow things down and try to
understand a little bit uh whereas like
you know I think the broader sort of um
ml research Community right now is
that's like forge on ahead
um which I think like you know sort of
makes sense actually because
um I think there's a lot of potential
upside from Ai and a lot of people see
that and want to like help solve
problems in the world right that can be
addressed by AI um this is that I guess
you know my intuition is okay well you
know it seems like there's a lot more
uncertainty for me right now about like
the potential downside it could be like
really huge so I want to work to try to
figure out what that could be
yeah and another thing as well and I
think Elias yukowski's made this
argument it's that um we don't really
know how close we are to artificial
general intelligence it might be like we
are 98 of the way there and we're very
very close to something you know
disastrous happening so I can kind of
get on board a little bit with that
argument but
um the problem I do have is a thing with
things like info hazards and things like
what I perceive to be almost
techno-luditism or paternalism is it
might really hinder our progress as
Society if we kind of like stop doing
this kind of fundamental research yeah
yeah so I'm like not that on board with
a techno blood ages and and with like
some of the more extreme stuff that's
been proposed um from like long-term
resume Community I guess yeah you said
something earlier about long-termism
um I guess like if you were to ask if I
were a long-term risk I'm not like
completely sure like I think I am on
board with the idea that equalizer like
that lives in the future matter equally
but I think because of uncertainty there
is maybe some implicit discount Factor
um like with our actions right
um but even like sort of supposing
long-termism I guess I'm not 100
consequent I think like you know there
are norms and values and like the rights
that like we should probably respect
um I'm like not a very good calculator
of like you know as you said like right
like the reward function is just like so
so complicated yeah I'm gonna need some
like really similar heuristics to help
guide me and like what I'm doing indeed
indeed well um all I want to say is I've
really enjoyed this conversation I I
appreciate it so much and thank you very
much great to meet you thank you so much